Bella a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo episodio di Resident Evil
Oh io sono Favij vero che possa piacervi
l'episodio di oggi Let's fucking go
che succede guarda
un ascensore
Ah devo butta' va bene ce l'ha ce l'ha
la palla da demolizione tipo questa che
fa per noi fai come Miley Cyrus Ashley
ti metti sulla palla di punizione
fai tu faccio io Miley Cyrus va bene
va bene
Ma sì falle fare il cazzo che vuole
tanto io devo ammazzare 2 milioni di
persone nel mentre sarebbe utile farlo
con la palla
a lei va bene
effettivamente ha senso così tu la
difendi
ti abbiamo un calcio speciale di guida
Minchia è brava comunque eh non so come
mai
Porca [__]
Mi sa che abbiamo attirato un po' di
gente però vabbè tanto ci penso io fa
niente Porca vacca
Aspetta che mi serve una granata
frammentazione
[Musica]
ok
perfetto
a posto Oddio
è uscito con la merda ok
ha una vita Ok devo stare attento che
non la faccia fuori va bene
ok Oh merda che cazzo è successo qua
Boh non ho ben capito che cosa sia
successo ma va bene Ci vuole tanto esce
lì perché qua è pieno di gente Porca
[__] non ho più colpi Uh
c'è il tipo aspetta aspetta aspetta
aspetta aspetta aspetta aspetta aspetta
aspetta
Allora mi serve la magnum qua
è morto non è morto attenzione che esci
ci sta
Ok
Esplodi occhio
a posto
ok
questo è andato giù c'è qua dentro c'era
tanta roba
Ok ne ho trovati un po'
bene
perfetto Oh merda dai
poi colpirli con la palla ah Ce l'ha
fatta non sta uscendo ancora gente
Madonna
Porca [__] sono usciti i parassiti
dove sono usciti Ecco quanti cazzo sono
sono stato pure bravo
che non ho fatto pure un miliardo aiuto
merda
c'è uno qua che cazzo ci fai Quaglia che
male eh aspetta che non è che posso fare
[Applauso]
ce l'ho fatta Sì
vabbè ma che male ragazzi
il giubbotto è messo male forse quello
il problema Guarda morite
Ok chi t'è muort intensifice nel finale
di dire ad esempio ok
Madonna che male ragazzi mi stanno
facendo Aspetta mi devo curare full
perfetto
[Musica]
Ah ma da qua sopra vedo meglio volendo
posso stare qua sopra bene Perfetto
è morto non è morto Ora è morto
Minchia non ho più colpi Raga non ho più
colpi per un cazzo devo usare Ah no ce
l'ho ce l'ho ce l'ho cazzate Ok
veloce figlio di [__] ok
Madonna ragazzi quanti cazzo sono
questo qua sta là a guardare Ashley
perfetto
ho finiti Madonna quanti soldi ho fatto
dono esce gente anche di qua Tanto già
che ci siamo Ah vedi che ce la porta lì
perfetto no perché in tutto sto casino
uno strano cadavere è stato avvistamento
che camminava in giro Minchia ha nel
laboratorio di incubazione c'è un nemico
speciale Ne ho trovate tutti indietro
per farne fuori uno dai Facciamo che no
dai Per il resto ce la siamo giocata
bene vai Ashley ci vai devi fare un
cazzo basta mi segui
stavo pensando Lavoriamo bene insieme Sì
ma secondo me c'è un Gap di età
abbastanza importante Quindi inutile che
Sì sì Ti ci vedo proprio
inizia a proteggere te stessa Beh
comunque prima dobbiamo uscire Vivi da
qui
si è messa nella posa rimorchio in tutto
ciò va bene
che cazzo di posto è questo deposito di
Ambra Ok
Ma c'è qualcosa Ecco di che cosa
parlavano
di qua
bello
lo vendiamo al mercante questo
merda l'avevano trovato qua dentro il
virus che schifo
che secondo me comunque dentro il
permafrost più o meno siamo messi così
benedizione finisce il gioco
teoricamente
Ah bello io utilizzerei un altro shampoo
osmond porta voce di nostro Signore
del Messia a posto morto
Porca [__] però gli ho fatto male
teoricamente
no no no questo video non deve essere
vietato io
Ah perché lui riesce proprio a
controllarti con il parassita Porca
merda no no no no no no no no no no no
[Musica]
figlia mia non fare Resistenza che cazzo
è successo
ma sta facendo Resistenza lei Ok
merda
Che culo e non si trovano facilmente le
munizioni della pistola
il mio fedele discepolo infliggerà la
vostra penitenza
figlia mia non avere timore Oh merda se
l'è presa lei
e liberati per sempre dalla paura
Ma che cazzo sono quelli nei teli cioè
gente e gente dentro un lenzuolo
Madonna ma che ansia
Boh
che Madonna che brutti che erano
Comunque quelli dentro
Sono d'accordo ma questa non si aprirà
mai si è aperta Vabbè allora seguilo Ma
scusa
così potevo andare Stealth
Effettivamente ora ci penso non so
perché vi ho sparato è venuto spontaneo
Che ti devo dire
Ma perché proprio un accampamento questo
Porca [__] devo andare Stealth si
ragazzi E vabbè dai ormai lo fanno hanno
fatto così pazienza sono stupido sono
stupido c'è anche uno con la motosega lo
sento
capito
Ho fatto un disastro raga Oh attento
Ok è morto così va bene apri apri apri
apri veloce
Ok Attenzione che c'è il tipo
Mangiafuoco
Benissimo Perfetto
prendi roba innata potente cos'è sto
rumore che sento Ogni tanto di come se
qualcuno avesse la motosega accesa
Sì sì
muoviti a morire che devo andare di
sotto Grazie allora aspetta o c'è uno
Minchia ci aveva l'elmo di ferro
a posto
è morto è morto ok
un sacco di piastrine
oh I am waiting
Ah sto aspettando e Sadler che l'ha
scritto Ok i miei che sta scia di sangue
che cazzo è e che cos'è la scoteca è
Fammi vedere qua c'è un'arma una volta
perché non me la dai Porca [__]
Ma [__] mi hai fatto cagare sotto
Ma tu sei scemo ma questo è scemo
ok
Vabbè usiamola allora bello
che è una rovina
stavo aspettando ma
tricola palle questo
non è vero
Sei sempre il solito hai una scarsa
capacità di giudizio ma volevo seccare
davvero Ma se pensi che ti lascerò
uscire da qui vivo
sei ancora più ingenuo di quanto
pensassi non puoi salvarla tu non puoi
salvare nessuno farla finita krause fare
il che di questi fanatici non ti riderà
gli uomini
E a che cosa serve
una vendetta contro il governo
pensi che vorrebbero questo
vendetta tu pensi che faccia tutto
questo per vendetta Allora dimmi Perché
lo fai vedi in quella giungla ho avuto
una rivelazione
la cosa più importante in questo mondo
il volo pieno e assoluto potere non mi
dire che si
trasformassi
ma almeno prima avevi un codice Ma vedi
onore
e guardati adesso
Basta coi ricordi
muovi il culo e apre il fuoco soldato
minchia
quindi combattiamo con le armi adesso
Porca [__] che cazzo di Arco hai
problemi non abbassati
Oh merda ho fatto saltare il muro
è morto
ma lo posso uccidere Orca [__]
così il letto
[__] Che male
Ahia Io sto provando dalla Magnum
ragazzi no me l'ha schivata [__]
Ok l'ho colpito
no ok È un colpo di Magnum è andato
Porca [__] quindi proprio una boss
Fight questa un colpo di Magnum mandato
a vuoto Porca merda
non lo vedo più È sparito Non è una boss
Fight ragazzi non ho capito
è la prima cosa che mi hai insegnato
è sparito Raga non c'è Oh
come cazzo hai fatto da dove è uscito
l'ho lanciato in mezzo al laser No più o
meno Minchia gli ho sparato alla Granata
che mi ha lanciato è stata una cosa
incredibile
ok
merda
Non è vero sono morto
non sono morto
non mi sta colpendo che culo Ma le posso
fare fuori ste cose
Sì Ok L'importante è questo perché sennò
Nel dubbio ragazzi Arca vacca attenzione
qua
ok
Stai attento che boss Fight strana raga
Porca merda che male
Dov'è
sei fortunato
che proprio non lo vedo io sto tizio
cioè proprio non so neanche come
combatterlo
lo posso colpire
Oh merda
[Musica]
aiuto che male non ha colpito
Eh ma qua dove vado lo sapevo non potevo
non potevo più non potevo prepararmi
aiuto
ho capito Ah [__]
[__] che brutta roba
non mi ha colpito ragazzi poteva andare
molto peggio mi fate scontrare contro
sto tizio per una volta
Porca [__] che male
e stai fermo
Minchia mi ha tirato una granata in
bocca e non mi sono fatto niente Tra
l'altro non so come adesso mi sono fatto
male adesso mi sono fatto male Va bene
allora uccidimi uccidimi testa di cazzo
allora aspetta un attimo che Ok
non funzionano Non è vero [__] aspetta
Porca [__] questo
un sacco come cazzo è possibile come fai
a rimanere ancora in piedi tollerato un
sacco
merda puoi passare in mezzo alle tue
stesse trappole ad esempio Secondo me no
Però vabbè
Eh no non ci passa proprio
in testa raga Oh a posto
Minchia gli ho ficcato un sacco di botte
Comunque
adesso si trasforma lo zio Io me lo
sento
Minchia Goku
secondo me secondo me è un po' tanto
anche meno
No però la magnum che comunque fa il suo
lavoro porca [__]
No è anche il braccio a differenza
effettivamente
è il momento della Fight
Ah no
ed è finito
È ora di finire
il tuo addestramento Al buio raga No sto
male No ragazzi al buio No vi prego
Oh merda adesso mi carica come cazzo la
testa Grazie come se non ci fosse un
domani non è vero
che male
E come lo colpisco Cioè posso batterlo
qua sotto
si può uscire da questo posto di merda
che già è buio
[Musica]
Ah sì sì si esce si esce fammi uscire
fammi uscire fammi uscire fammi uscire
Minchia come lo schivato vai
[Musica]
ok ok ok Che
bravo bravo bravo bravo bravissimo
bravissimo va bene
L'importante è che io ci veda Poi per il
resto fa niente Oh Qua ci sta una bella
boss Fight Questa è una bella Arena
non abbiamo ancora finito l'ultima
lezione inizia proprio
sì voltiamo di un caricatore Ma porca
[__] merda
No ora te la do io una lezione Oh quanta
sicurezza
ottima
Porca [__] ragazzi va bene Io c'ho una
paura immonda ad utilizzare la mia
Magnum perché se utilizzo la magnum
Secondo me mi incula Nel senso che mi
schiva i proiettili
proverò effettivamente non è che posso
andare avanti senza un cazzo
Madonna non gliene frega niente a lui di
quello che sì gli faccio io zero bravo
eh Ho solo la pistola e la potenziare
perfetto bravissimo
sei perfetto
[Musica]
Non si è fatto un cazzo
non si fa un cazzo bene ottimo
Allora qualcosa si è fatto se è cambiata
la fase
l'ho colpito non si capisce non so che
non si capisce solo colpiscono
ok
niente Madonna che botta
[Applauso]
puoi rifiutare
Pensa a quanto forza
bellissimo diventare un
posto
con la magnum bellissimo Beh questo
questo qua gli ho levato eh
un Head shot con la magnum è sempre
importante ragazzi Quindi
quindi
io non ci penserei due volte
[Musica]
Forza avanti
ma proprio gli ho fatto malissimo
dai spingilo
Bravo Così si fa cazzo
non vede mica lasciarlo in vita Sto
stronzo
sei un ponte di cazzo quindi non mi
farai pena verso la fine sicuramente
cioè io senza mutazioni l'ho fatto gli
ho fatto un culo quadrato
a maggior ragione
bene
controllo l'assalto Ah la mia cara
Magnum Meno male che esiste ho lasciato
un po' di piante verdi in giro eh
effettivamente Però vabbè sti cazzi raga
si vola
Ma sì fottitene
ma mi sa che questa è la fine del
capitolo ragazzi sarà l'ultimo il 15
perché mi ricordavo più o meno
a grandi linee che siamo verso il finale
quindi credo siano 15
Madonna Ok adesso mitraglio tutti Eh
ragazzi me ne fotto devo arrivare là Va
bene
Oh finalmente siamo tornati qua
a merda
deve essere il loro santuario
no Finché non vedo un cazzo tra l'altro
quel coso Vabbè perso il santuario
Eh se quello stronzo mi avesse dato
mezzo punto cioè qualcosa da venderti
niente non c'ho nulla da vendere vabbè
Arrivederci
pure C'è un sacco di gente qua
[Musica]
Ma che hai detto Mierda adesso
che cazzo sta succedendo che cazzo
succede cazzo
Grazie che cazzo che vi prende Ma cos'è
l'elicottero non è mio alleato
un elicottero d'attacco che gli ho mai
segnato
io sono Mike ora Facciamoglielo vedere
Sì ma ti rendi conto che mi hai colpito
anche a me prima sei un testa di merda
va bene Venite qua ragazzi
Si ma ragazzi Sì ma mi fai male mi fai
male piano Madonna oh
drogati Tu ce la fai a sparargli faccio
io eh
Ok meglio che faccio io
bene
Beh comunque l'elicottero È
straordinario
fratello mi devi dare una mano
Meno male che esisti
Minchia Ma vi pare raga
ok
Beh Ne abbiamo fatti fuori un miliardo
Eh ma perché bombardi così
Sì sì fai tu
prima
pausa me la prendo ma qua c'è gente così
lanciarazzi porca di quella [__] che
male Ma fallo prima
Fallo prima cazzo Madonna che male Mi ha
fatto mi ha beccato in faccia mi ha
beccato col lanciarazzi in faccia
[__] non ho più Cure Minchia
gliel'ha fatta salta dopo dopo che mi
hanno sparato in bocca grande
Complimenti Grazie del tempismo aspetta
sì ma sì ma sì
bravissimo Vabbè adesso Adesso è servita
effettivamente Uh ne ho trovato un altro
display medico Michia Meno male
cazzo sta roba Ok Mi sa che vengo a
fartelo fuori No non è vero
[Musica]
Va bene arrivo arrivo
Eh ho capito ma non posso entrare No
devo fare il giro che cazzo dici Io devo
fare di qua non tipo lo vedo aspetta
aspetta aspetta aspetta aspetta aspetta
aspetta aspetta Lo sapevo
preso
Ok perfetto zona che male
bellissimo come l'ho fatto fuori questa
storia incredibile
Il coltello è quello nuovo che mi ha
dato il tizio immagino non so se
venderlo perché chi cazzo lo usa il
coltello devo ripararmi anche l'armatura
che saltata in aria però vabbè Quello
appena arriva il Mercante non ho capito
bene come dovrei salire Vabbè ma in
qualche modo salirò tipo penso di qua e
di qua sicuramente è giusto
giorno Aspetta
il prossimo
Minchia quanti cazzo siete
prendi tutto il tempo che vuoi zio
perfetto
Madonna che male chi cazzo mi ha
lanciato qualcosa
c'è lo zio lì occhio
ho finito i colpi Vai vai di pistola vai
di pistola sono morti questi qua dietro
Non è vero non me ne ero accorto Porca
[__] Meno male Eh mi sa che c'è
qualcuno vuole lanciarazzi occhio
spara Eh ma Minchia perfetto ha sarebbe
stato figo se avessi colpito anche
questo qua Però vabbè meglio
[Musica]
No non volevo colpire lui volevo colpire
quello dietro Eccolo che non ha ucciso
nessuno però è stato figo
perfetto c'è gente qua Salve
vai vai vai vai vai vai vai vai vai vai
vai vai vai vai vai vai vai vai non so
neanche dove cazzo sto andando ragazzi
ormai vado per inerzia avanti
uh la mitraglietta
potevo usarla Prima effettivamente
sarebbe stato meglio Ah con la
mitraglietta posso fare fuori la
contraerea
Ah sì lo dovevo fare davvero Ah
oh merda
ok
la porta la dovresti sfondare tu zio c'è
una porta qua effettivamente siete
accorti sfondamela bravo
Grazie arrivederci un merda merda c'è un
aiutino lo zio un aiutino
Ma come
Ma che cazzo dici come fico ma che
elicottero c'hai della Chicco Ma cos'è
qua In che senso Ma cosa ce la faccio
[Musica]
[__]
ok Vabbè finora ce l'ho fatta davvero
però è un miracolo Ragazzi
allora ok No vabbè ragazzi Qua c'è un
bordello c'è un bordello
Ma che cazzo devo fare io qua
[Musica]
ok
con la musica epica tutto questo me lo
sta facendo fare va bene Meno male che
c'è un tipo dietro che è stupido
ok
il prossimo
poi il tipo mi ha detto pure tranquillo
ce la fai cioè mi sbeffeggia pure Ah
perché c'è una mitraglietta qua
utile Porca [__]
mitraglietta
ok
Madonna ha fatto giusto in tempo guarda
Adesso vai giù vai giù vai giù vai giù
vai giù perfetto
perfetto Sono stato bravissimo Sono
stato bravissimo poi mi ha beccato
questi però vabbè non ci ho fatto caso
ok
finiti qua devo tirare la leva quindi
uno
adesso arriverà altra gente No Sì ma
arriva altra gente io che cazzo parlo
perfetto
trovo i due Ah non c'è neanche uno
ancora qualcuno Eccolo lì però qualcuno
Boh ho finito i colpi Eh non mi fate
incazzare ok
veramente non è morto
non è vero che c'è uno di questi [__]
di tua madre chi è che mi ha colpito Ok
mi frullo
eh Raga se c'è questo è dura però
aspetta che provo a sparargli attraverso
dai
Eh perché c'è gente sopra [__]
mi servirebbe sparargli tranquillamente
con la mitraglietta sto qua sarebbe
utile
pure
[Musica]
Minchia
è stato stra utile Meno male che sei
stato fermo zio potevi farmi fuori ma te
ne sei [__] Vabbè Meno male
ok La porta è aperta Eh praticamente
c'è altra gente c'è altra gente ma
questo qua è morto Vabbè quindi questo
perfetto chi cazzo c'è a questo qua
molto bene raga Molto bene molto bene la
proiettili come stiamo Non benissimo
Però vabbè
grazie sull'elicottero Sì sì arrivo
[Musica]
Sì ma dovremmo salvare tipo
tutto questo per niente finora
A meno che l'elicottero non cada dal
momento all'altro
lanciarazzi da qualche parte
No che cazzo è
merda gli insetti
leva Sparagli non fanno schifo cioè con
due colpi ma con due colpi di secchi
questi qua di merda
Minchia abbiamo sbaragliato tutti quanti
con due insetti di merda Sei andato giù
Minchia allora
finisce qua siamo quasi in dirittura
d'arrivo verso la fine ragazzi Spero che
vi sia piacendo perché a me essendo
quasi al termine posso già dire che per
me è stato è un capolavoro Ma andiamo
verso il finale e poi ne riparliamo
iscrivetevi al canale ragazzi lasciate
un bel commento e un mi piace e noi come
sempre ci vediamo al prossimo video
Bella raga bella ragazzi
morirò prima o poi però vabbè